hey this is super super interesting
the top rated program on fox business
the lou dobbs program has been cancelled
blue dobbs tonight is the name of the
show
now most of you i'm i'm guessing know
about fox news
fox business is sort of like the less
well-rated little sister or brother
to fox news and the most popular
show on that channel was lou dobbs
tonight
lou dobbs has been cancelled abruptly
uh fox business network uh announced
on a friday that lou dobbs program
is effective immediately off the air
there's going to be an
interim show starting on monday
and it's weird because this is the
highest rate of
rate highest rated show
the channel doesn't do that well the
best thing they had going from the
standpoint of ratings was the lou dobbs
program
and now he's gone he often had twice
the rating of the show that led into his
show
that's really rare in television and lou
dobbs is
a veteran anchor at this point i mean
he's out of his mind when it comes to
his political views
but he's been around for a long time
he's sort of a known entity
and um what appears to be going on here
is that fox business as much as fox news
newsmax oan
they are very worried about legal
exposure
because of the absolutely uh
out of this world lies that were being
perpetrated
and perpetuated and uh spread by lou
dobbs and his guests lou dobbs had
the the whole uh what would you call
them the whole gang
the whole brady bunch on his program
sidney powell
and you know all of the people that were
spreading the election lies about the
election was stolen by joe biden from
donald trump all of this stuff
and so my reaction to this is very much
like my reaction
to republican officials from the bush
era leaving the republican party which
we talked about last week
it's very much like my reaction to
newsmax airing a piece saying
we believe the results of the election
or whatever
fox is taking this step because they got
destroyed in a nearly 300-page legal
complaint
about their election fraud coverage lou
dobbs
was as big a player as anybody in that
legal complaint
he was one of the primary promulgators
of
the election fraud nonsense and now
they're at risk of serious financial
consequences
now i think uh so so as far as
ethics or whatever this is merely a
financial decision that's it
i think a question that needs to be
asked more so i mean listen newsmax and
oan
they are not what fox is in terms of
corporate
infrastructure will any executives at
fox be fired for allowing lou dobbs to
spread this nonsense for month
months because any one of them could
have stopped this very quickly
and they opted not to do it until they
were in legal hot water
as far as lou dobbs i don't know i don't
know he's no spring chicken
maybe he'll go in the direction of
newsmax or oan but even they've been
careful about the voter fraud stuff over
the last couple of weeks for the same
reasons huge legal liability
now one other thought and we're going to
get to this a little later
over the weekend a whole bunch of fox
shows
janine pirro jesse waters a bunch of
others
dated segments on cancel culture they
didn't mention this
they didn't mention this i mean listen
this is a conservative getting cancelled
right
but somehow this cancellation doesn't
play
well into the story of social media and
democrats and left-wingers and
communists and socialists and marxists
and whoever else
canceling conservatives but isn't this
what their outrage porn stories have
been all about
conservatives getting canceled except
this one's by fox news and it's for
legal
reasons of significant financial
consequence the fact
but one last thought this was the
highest rated show on fox
business that says a lot about what's
going on at fox business like what on
earth is going on at fox business that
lou dobbs
is the highest rated show so my
prediction is we will see more of this
not because anybody's found a moral
compass not because anybody
of these wacky right-wing network
networks have all of a sudden decided
that we really need to value truth
uh no these are merely business
decisions and they are worried about
having to pay out a ton
a ton of money we'll have more about
this on our instagram page which you can
find
at david pakman show find me on
instagram
david.pacman you may not have known this
but when you see me
sitting here on the show i am often
wearing shirts by a company called teddy
stratford i asked them to be a sponsor
because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that it
looks really good
and just all around they cut the entire
shirt in a specific way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman
at checkout